bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de Parlement Hebdo en compagnie
d'Emmanuel Kessler bonjour Emmanuel au
menu de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine le mea culpa
de la France à propos de la Tunisie nous
avons sous-estimé les aspirations du
peuple tunisien à la liberté reconnaît
Nicolas Sarkozy le président qui
justifie cependant la discrétion
française par le devoir de réserve d'un
pays vis-à-vis de ses ex-colonis le chef
de l'État qui est revenu cette semaine
sur un thème qui lui est cher la lutte
contre la récidive criminelle après la
disparition de Laetitia à Pornic il
exige des initiatives rapides mais il
aurait renoncé dans la semaine à en
passer par une nouvelle loi qui aurait
été la sixième en septembre enfin
moraliser la vie publique c'est
l'objectif d'un rapport rendu cette
semaine par la commission sur les les
ministres cabinets et aux fonctionnaires
de l'État devraient par exemple faire
des déclarations d'intérêts chaque année
question que va faire maintenant
l'Élysée de ce rapport et notre invité
cette semaine pour commenter toute cette
actualité c'était Elisabeth Guigou
bonjour Merci d'être sur le plateau de
la Chaîne parlementaire Public Sénat et
LCP Assemblée Nationale vous êtes je le
rappelle député socialiste de
Seine-Saint-Denis vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ancienne ministre
vous avez occupé plusieurs portefeuilles
à faires européens justice emploi vous
publiez ces jours-ci pour une Europe
juste au cherche midi un livre
d'entretien avec Véronique Augé on aura
l'occasion de revenir sur certains
aspects vous faites partie de la
génération Mitterrand celle qui est
arrivée au pouvoir il est exactement 30
ans et qui rêvent désormais de
reconquérir l'Élysée enfin en 2012
première question peut-être certains Ops
comme François Hollande ou
Jean-Christophe comme adélice 17
semaines que le PS est un peu parti dans
une machine à perdre vous partagez cet
avis notamment sur les non voilà je
comprends pas qu'on passe son temps à
s'auto flageller comme ça alors que le
rôle de responsable politique du PS
devrait être plutôt de mettre en valeur
le travail important qui s'y fait même
s'il est pas encore très visible et ce
n'est pas encore abouti voilà le PS sous
la direction de Martine Aubry s'est
remise au travail nous avons tenu
plusieurs conventions dont une
convention internationale dans
lesquelles Jean-Christophe camballée a
joué un rôle important qui a produit je
crois des propositions intéressantes et
fortes sur l'Europe sur l'Afrique par
exemple on peut dire au vu des
événements aujourd'hui à quel point nous
avons besoin évidemment nous Européens
de nous tourner davantage vers notre Sud
donc je trouve que nous avons mis en
place un comité du projet le calendrier
pour le projet défini nous allons avoir
une convention du projet présidé par la
première secrétaire fin mai ensuite le
calendrier des primaires et est fait
voilà alors après il y a des péripéties
il y a des clapotis il y a des
déclarations
voilà on a un calendrier il faut le
respecter vous savez François Mitterrand
m'a appris nous a appris quelque chose
il faut maîtriser son temps alors le
temps politique n'est pas le temps
médiatique ça c'est vrai moi je
comprends que vous ayez vos contraintes
mais nous avons les nôtres il y a aucune
raison de bousculer un calendrier qui a
été adopté d'ailleurs à l'unanimité
par l'ensemble des dirigeants du parti
alors c'est vrai que moi je suis pas
contente non plus de certaines
déclarations voilà je trouve que on
ferait mieux de dire les dirigeants tous
les dirigeants et dirigeants du PS
devraient se fixer une seule règle dire
aux françaises et aux Français ce que
nous allons proposer pour résoudre leurs
problèmes il est temps de le faire
on passe on va y revenir d'ailleurs sur
certains dossiers de la semaine on passe
à la journée de lundi Tunisie le malaise
français
conférence de presse de Nicolas Sarkozy
lundi sur les dossiers internationaux
pour la première fois le chef de l'État
s'explique sur l'attitude de la France
face à la révolution tunisienne et il
fait un début de mea culpa Millan Poyet
devant le siège du gouvernement tunisien
ce matin la caravane de la liberté
arrive à son terme 4 jours de marche
depuis plusieurs villes de province pour
rejoindre la capitale et exiger la
démission du gouvernement jugé trop
proche de l'ancien président Ben Ali
dans le même temps dans les écoles et
les lycées les enseignants ont entamé
une grève illimité les Tunisiens ne
semblent pas en avoir fini avec leur
évolution révolution marquée en France
dans un premier temps par le silence du
gouvernement puis par certaines
maladresses ce matin en conférence de
presse début de mai à culpa du président
de la République il y avait une
désespérance une souffrance
un sentiment d'étouffé dont il faut il
nous faut le reconnaître nous n'avions
pas pris la juste mesure sans doute nous
avons sous-estimé nous la France cette
aspiration de nos amis tunisiens à la
liberté mais dans le même temps Nicolas
Sarkozy se défend il invoque un certain
devoir de réserve face à ce qu'il
appelle de vieux réflexes coloniaux je
revendique
une certaine réserve lorsqu'il s'agit de
commenter les événements de pays qui ont
été la France et qu'ils ne le sont plus
plus tard Nicolas Sarkozy défend aussi
sa ministre des Affaires étrangères
Michel Alliot-Marie invoquant une
éventuelle maladresse dans la forme pas
dans le fond et d'ajouter que la France
a accueilli durant plusieurs années des
opposants au régime tunisien coïncidence
avec l'actualité le parquet de Paris
vient d'ouvrir une enquête préliminaire
sur les biens en France de
l'ex-président tunisien
est-ce que vous partagez Elisabeth
Guigou cette idée du devoir de réserve
de la France vis-à-vis de pays que la
colonisé dans l'histoire
certainement pas à la France de dire à
ses peuples ce qu'il doit faire mais
c'est certainement la responsabilité de
la France d'accompagner
par les encouragements à la fois dans
une parole politique et puis par aussi
des gestes concrets d'accompagner les
mouvements de démocratisation et je
pense que notre le gouvernement pas la
France le gouvernement
c'est lourdement trompé il a gravement
failli parce que les déclarations de
Madame aliou-marie elles ont fait
beaucoup de mal beaucoup de mal moi j'ai
eu énormément de réactions de mes amis
de l'autre côté de la Méditerranée pas
seulement en Tunisie mais en Algérie au
Maroc mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
comment est-ce que la France peut
s'exprimer comme ça et Madame Adium
Marie elle a certainement pas pris cette
initiative toute seule
donc on comprend la gêne les
explications qui ont été données ne sont
pas suffisantes cette affaire est un peu
soldée mais je crois que je crois que en
réalité
le Quai d'Orsay
n'a pas apprécié correctement la
situation il suffisait d'ailleurs on n'a
pas besoin de télégramme diplomatique
confidentiel pour ça il suffit juste de
regarder la télévision de lire les
journaux d'aller sur les sites internet
pour voir ce qui se passait donc le
gouvernement et le président a voulu
être aveugle
curru jusqu'au bout que
le monde a été un peu en retard sans
doute même le Parti socialiste aussi
d'ailleurs faut être honnête personne ne
pouvait prévoir le moment évidemment
mais enfin le mouvement de fonds qui se
passait quand on savait aussi que
depuis assez longtemps quand même
plusieurs mouvements se conjuguaient si
vous voulez d'abord l'éducation qui
s'était propagée pas seulement en
Tunisie mais dans d'autres pays aussi le
fait qu'il y a énormément
j'ai pas parfaite sans doute mais voilà
la situation est quand même différente
de démocratie pardon vous qualifier le
Maroc de démocratie je pense que vous
savez je ne sais pas parce que nous
avons nos propres standards et je pense
que nous n'avons pas alors en effet à
les imposer aux autres je pense qu'il y
a encore des marges de progression et
d'ailleurs les démocrates au Maroc le
disent mais la situation n'est pas
exactement comparable qui était celle de
la Tunisie en revanche la Tunisie était
plus avancée sur l'alphabétisation par
exemple sur la scolarisation notamment
dans les milieux ruraux
ce que vous êtes en train de nous dire
non parce que c'est pas tout à fait non
c'est pas exactement comparable non non
bien sûr d'abord d'un côté vous avez une
monarchie qui est ancienne de l'autre
avec un jeune roi
d'autres côtés vous avez un dictateur
qui est là depuis plus de 20 ans qui
commence à être
âgés quand même
voilà mais c'est vrai que
voilà il faut être il faut soutenir je
crois toutes les mouvements de
démocrate il faut être aux côtés de ces
peuples sans leur imposer quoi que ce
soit car ils doivent on ne peut jamais
décréter la démocratie de l'extérieur
c'est à eux-mêmes de trouver leur chemin
alors cette conférence de presse de
Nicolas Sarkozy ce lundi avait pour
premier thème l'économie mondiale
quelles ambition pour la France qui
préside le G20 et le G8 jusqu'en 2012
Nicolas Sarkozy les a énumérés et parmi
ses travaux d'Hercule pour une meilleure
gouvernance mondiale il a reparlé d'une
taxe sur les transactions financières on
l'écoute
la France est favorable à une taxe sur
les transactions financières
la France considère que cette taxe est
morale
compte tenu de la crise financière que
nous venons de traverser
que cette taxe est utile pour dissuader
la spéculation
je pourrais m'en expliquer si vous aviez
des questions
et que cet axe est efficace pour trouver
de nouvelles ressources pour le
développement alors une taxe sur les
transactions financières pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
il y a des au développement ça pourrait
être une proposition du programme
socialiste ça l'est c'est une
proposition dont vous êtes d'accord avec
le Président c'est une proposition du
Parti socialiste européen depuis
longtemps depuis plusieurs mois ce cri
noir sur blanc la question est de savoir
à quel taux on va la voir nous nous
disons une taxe sur les activités
financières de
0,05%. et ce que nous disons surtout
c'est qu'il faut sortir des
proclamations d'intention on est au
sixième G20 depuis que la crise a éclaté
à l'été 2008 alors on ne cesse pas
d'avoir des proclamations sur le fait
qu'on va lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux rétablir de la régulation
financière là maintenant très bien créer
une taxe financière il faut le faire il
faut être pour pouvoir le faire il faut
que les Américains soient d'accord il
faut créer d'abord les conditions pour
que en Europe les propositions de la
France celles-ci je la soutiens
totalement mais il y en a d'autres
puis cette soutenue or et ça c'est un
travail politique et diplomatique de
longue haleine et c'est vrai que on ne
se donne pas les meilleures chances
d'avoir le soutien de tous les Européens
des Allemands en premier lieu mais de
tous les autres quand on tire en
permanence la couverture à soi
pour avoir travaillé beaucoup des années
des années avec François Mitterrand sur
les questions européennes je sais que
une entente et une position européenne
lorsqu'elle vient lorsqu'elle est
proposée par la France ensuite ça se
construit avec les autres et je regrette
ce que nous ne soyons pas en position
alors on peut dire on peut déclamer la
télévision très bien est-ce que ça va se
faire je le souhaite j'attends Nicolas
Sarkozy joue trop franco français dans
sa présidence bien sûr ça fait trois ans
maintenant que nous attendons des
résultats sur les paradis fiscaux sur
une vraie
régulationnel évidemment qui a des
résistances mais enfin les États-Unis
d'Obama sont allés plus loin que
l'Europe sur un certain nombre de sujets
et je pense que nous avons besoin
de resserrer la cohésion européenne et
certaines attitudes notamment l'année
dernière sur les Roms sont certainement
pas allés dans ce sens on passe à
l'actualité de mardi l'euthanasie un
débat inédit au Sénat
permettre à une personne majeure dans
des cas extrêmes d'être médicalement
aider à mourir c'était le sens d'une
proposition de loi qui une première a
été débattue dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
mardi mais le texte a finalement été
vidé de sa substance après la prise de
position hostile de François Fillon les
explications de Marie brémo
les détracteurs de l'euthanasie semblent
avoir eu raison du texte de loi qui fait
polémique au Sénat alors que des
centaines de personnes prolife
manifestaient ce matin devant la Haute
Assemblée au même moment la commission
des affaires sociales vidait la
proposition de loi légalisant
l'euthanasie de sa substance les
articles de la loi ont été supprimés par
la même commission qui avait adopté le
texte de loi la semaine dernière il y a
une seule explication possible le
gouvernement a donné des consignes et à
demander qu'il n'y ait pas de vagues ces
derniers jours le gouvernement François
Fillon en tête n'a pas ménagé ses
efforts pour battre le rappel contre le
texte la sénatrice à l'initiative de cet
amendement de suppression avance une
procédure parlementaire habituelle et
réfute avoir coupé court à la discussion
n'a pas clos un débat puisque le
règlement du Sénat permet au contraire
que le débat ait lieu en séance plénière
dans la nuit une majorité de sénateurs à
clos le débat 370 d'entre eux ont voté
contre la légalisation de l'euthanasie
le Sénat a-t-il bien fait selon vous et
Elizabeth Guigou de rejeter ce texte
moi je pense que on peut pas légiférer
sur une question aussi difficile
douloureuse sur lesquelles chacun alors
quel que soit son appartenance politique
à sa sensibilité
je crois qu'on peut pas légiférer dans
la précipitation je pense que il y a une
loi léonétique a été adoptée à une très
très large majorité enfin toute tout
groupe en 2005 du groupe politique
confondus et qui je crois établit un
cadre qui permet à la fois de ne pas
avoir d'acharnement thérapeutique parce
que les personnes sont en fin de vie et
d'autre part de soulager les souffrances
par un consensus des soignants avec les
familles cette loi malheureusement et
qui prévoit le développement des soins
palliatifs pour les personnes en fin de
vie cette loi malheureusement on sait
qu'elle est très mal appliquée il y a
simplement on nous dit que à peine 20%
des personnes en fin de vie peuvent
bénéficier en milieu hospitalier de
soins palliatifs c'est pas normal donc
moi ce que je souhaite parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a quelques cas très très
spectaculaires d'ailleurs très marginaux
mais mais évidemment
extrême qui ne rentre pas
dans le cadre de la loi Leonetti je
pense qu'il faut en débattre calmement
ce que je souhaite c'est que surtout sur
un sujet comme ça on se précipite pas
pour les giférés à nouveau qu'on évalue
les tendus des soins palliatifs je crois
que la priorité des priorités c'est
évidemment de les généraliser pour les
personnes en fin de vie qu'on évalue les
effets de laonetti sont l'application et
puis qu'ensuite en effet on se pose la
question de savoir s'il faut d'autres
mesures donc cette initiative au moins
le mérite de de reposer les problèmes de
la prostitution de la bien sûr sur ces
bases sociétés il faut constamment
alimenter la réflexion et c'est vrai
allez on se mardi se repose aussi à la
question de la récidive pour les crimes
sexuels laetitia a disparu dans la
région de Pornic et le suspect est un
homme déjà condamné très foi dont une
fois pour viol en visite dans la région
Nicolas Sarkozy exige de son
gouvernement et des parlementaires UMPS
des initiatives rapides on l'écoute
je souhaite que la justice travaille
très vite
très efficacement afin que toute la
vérité soit connue
je recevais je recevrai la famille
dès mon retour
mais je veux vous dire que la récidive
criminelle n'est pas une fatalité
et je ne me contenterai pas
d'une enquête sans suite
je le dis très sereinement
mais il y aura pas une enquête de plus
on dira aux Français que tout a été
parfait sauf une petite jeune fille qui
ne demandait qu'à vivre
et qui a disparu c'est pas possible
faut attendre de voir
mais si c'est l'indicible
faudra des décisions
et pas des commissions de réflexion donc
des décisions pas des commissions de
réflexion vous qui a été ministre de la
Justice qu'est-ce que comme que vous
inspire ce plus jamais ça de Nicolas
Sarkozy
dans mes chacun d'entre nous est pauvre
une émotion profonde
devant un tel crime
toujours pas retrouvé cette jeune fille
donc c'est c'est vrai que c'est
insupportable voilà alors maintenant il
s'agit de savoir au-delà là encore
de grande déclaration qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire d'efficace
nous savons très bien que pour ces
criminels dangereux
qui sortent de prison c'est le cas au
terme de leur père
il faut un suivi étroit
or vous avez des conseillers d'insertion
et probation qui sont des travailleurs
sociaux du ministère de la Justice ils
ont en moyenne 130 dossiers chacun de
criminels présumé criminel là sur ce
mais dans la région il disait 800
détenus ou exécutenus non suivis
dans certaines
non suivis par des conseillers
d'insertion donc si vous voulez voilà où
est le problème le problème il est que
on devrait dès le début de la peine dans
la prison suivre
certainement surtout les délinquants
sexuels moi j'ai fait voter une loi en
98 qui demande ça qu'il instaurait dès
le début de la peine et évidemment tout
au long de la peine et ensuite à la
sortie un suivi qui soit à la fois
social judiciaire médicale
de sorte que la personne comme c'est le
cas d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de
démocraties du nord de l'Europe
d'ailleurs ou au Canada soit en serrés
dans l'espace de filet de surveillance
hors les murs
qui soient
véritablement qui encadre et qui soit
aux aguets si vous voulez de tout risque
de récidive voilà malheureusement on
manque dramatiquement de moyens alors
plutôt que de prévoir de mettre des
assesseurs au juge dans les tribunaux
correctionnels parce que là aussi il
faut les payer les jurés populaires
suivi sympathique par ailleurs je pense
qu'on ferait mieux de doter de se
préoccuper des vraies urgences en voici
une particulière et puis l'Assemblée
nationale a également voté la réforme de
la garde à vue à une large majorité le
texte prévoit la présence de l'avocat
tout au long de cette étape de l'enquête
pour se conformer aux obligations
européennes le PS c'est abstenu sur ce
texte en 2000 vous aviez fait voter une
première étape avec en principe la
possibilité pour quelqu'un de
s'entretenir avec un avocat dès la
première heure de garde à vue alors
pourquoi ne pas avoir voté pour ce qui
constitue aux yeux de tout le monde un
progrès du droit et qui va dans le sens
de ce que réclame l'Europe qui est votre
un de vos soucis j'allais dire non mais
le gouvernement a fait voter cette loi
contraint et forcé par les décisions
parler décisions européennes par le
Conseil constitutionnel et par la Cour
de cassation donc il a fini par se
résigner à faire voter une loi qui
rétablit pour les personnes gardées à
vue il y en a quand même 800 000 dont
200 000 pour des infractions routières
le droit de se taire que j'avais
instauré dans la loi en 2000 la loi sur
la présomption d'innocence et les droits
des victimes le droit de se taire après
que ce droit de se taire ait été
supprimé par les lois perles en 2003
2004 qui en effet
rétablissent qui s'était perdu la
présence de l'avocat et qui va
d'ailleurs plus loin ce je salue puisque
l'avocat est présent pendant les
interrogatoires façon d'ailleurs alors
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai pas voté ce
texte qui représente un progrès par
rapport à la situation actuelle pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que la
présence de l'avocat n'est pas
absolument automatique que le procureur
peut décider que ça va on comprend qu'il
y a des cas où il faut faire attention
par exemple des réseaux de trafic de
drogue peuvent s'organiser et profiter
de l'avocat à partir du moment où
l'avocat n'a pas accès au dossier
pendant la garde à vue ceci ne peut pas
se produire nous parlons de la présence
de l'avocat pendant les interrogatoires
c'est tout d'ailleurs c'est l'intérêt à
mon avis des policiers parce que il y a
toujours un soupçon qui pèse contenu des
conditions matérielles déplorables dans
lesquelles et les policiers souffrent
aussi évidemment s'effectue les garde à
vue je pense que la présence de l'avocat
d'un avocat qui est là pour assister à
côté de son client peut être de nature à
dissiper les soupçons de maltraitance
mais si je n'ai pas voté ce texte aussi
c'est surtout parce que le contrôle de
la garde à vue et notamment sa
prolongation devrait être réalisée par
le juge de la liberté de la détention
qui est une disposition qui avait été
votée d'ailleurs par la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale et que le
gouvernement a fait retirer donc nous
nous sommes abstenus pourquoi pour dire
ben nous ne votons pas compte parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a un progrès par
rapport à la situation actuelle mais
nous estimons qu'il aurait fallu aller
plus loin avoir une loi qui soit
véritablement alors elle tout à fait
conforme au standard européen car le
paradoxe c'est que l'Europe nous demande
avec insistance de réformer le statut du
parquet pour rendre les procureurs enfin
indépendants dans leur carrière du
pouvoir politique or ceci et nous
l'avons souligné dans le débat n'est
toujours pas fait et évidemment tant que
ce sera le cadre de protester bien sûr
et ça tant que ce sera le cas nous ne
serons pas en conformité avec les
standards européens allez on passe au
mercredi quand un rapport s'attaque au
conflit d'intérêt dans la vie publique
la commission sur les conflits
d'intérêts en ce mercredi son Rapport au
Président de la République avec des
préconisations très sérieuses pour
imposer des règles de transparence au
ministre à leur entourage et à la haute
fonction publique déclaration d'intérêt
obligatoire interdiction de cumules qui
s'inscrirait dans une loi un rapport
très exigeant qui suscite des réactions
contrastées Johann Rollin
au cœur du rapport présenté ce matin un
préalable définir dans la loi la notion
de conflit d'intérêt au terme de quatre
mois de travail et de 70 auditions ces
trois auteurs formulent une série de
propositions ambitieuses à commencer par
la suivante l'obligation pour tous les
membres du gouvernement ainsi que pour
tous les hauts responsables publics de
déclarer leurs intérêts financiers leurs
anciennes responsabilités et celles de
leurs proches une idée déjà détaillée
par Martin et Hirt dans son livre choc
pour en finir avec les conflits
d'intérêts et soutenus par de nombreux
parlementaires de l'opposition je crois
qu'on a besoin en France de ne pas être
dans l'implicite mais avoir des règles à
laquelle on peut se fier et qui soit
finalement au cœur de la recherche de la
confiance aujourd'hui une perte de
confiance on l'a vu beaucoup dans le
secteur de la santé la gauche craintes
en effet une simple réponse cosmétique à
la faire BIRT Bettencourt élément
déclencheur du rapport dans la majorité
d'autres s'interrogent la mise en place
d'une haute autorité de contrôle pas
question de se lancer dans une chasse
aux sorcières si vous mettez des règles
excessives vous allez finir par mener
l'action publique avec des gens
totalement
asexués incompétent ne connaissant rien
à rien et n'ayant de contact avec
personne la France rabattre beaucoup
plus avancée outre le rapport sauvé un
groupe de travail spécifique a été créé
en octobre dernier à l'Assemblée pour
définir des règles de bonne conduite
pour l'ensemble des députés il devrait
rendre ses conclusions dès le mois
prochain
en tant que représentante du PS sont
évidemment pour l'instant simplement des
préconisations on va voir ce que
l'Elysée va en faire ce serait quand
même une révolution des mentalités moi
je trouve que c'est un excellent rapport
mais j'y retrouve d'ailleurs
pratiquement toutes les propositions que
j'avais eu l'occasion de faire au nom du
parti socialiste donc je crois que c'est
un très très bon rapport
ne parle pas des parle chanteur qui ont
leur propre route de travail est-ce que
on pourrait s'inspirer de ce rapport
alors ce que j'ai j'espère c'est deux
choses d'abord que s'agissant des noms
parlementaires c'est-à-dire des
ministres et des hauts fonctionnaires
des membres de cabinet
effectivement une loi qui traduise en
acte législatif cette c'est
préconisations pour l'instant c'est que
des propositions ça ça dépend du
gouvernement du président de la
République de proposer ça en particulier
l'interdiction pour les ministres
d'exercer un mandat exécutif local il
trouve que ça on doit absolument tenir
bon sur cette préconisation vous avez
évoqué vous-même les déclarations
d'intérêts les bons et puis il y a une
deuxième chose à faire puisque la
mission sauvée n'était pas compétente
pour les parlementaires c'est que le
Parlement Assemblée nationale et c'est
là définissent pour les parlementaires
des règles qui soient aussi exigeante
que celle du rapport public aussi
bien sûr est rendu public bien sûr je
crois que ce serait avocat d'affaires
alors c'est compatible ou pas pour vous
je crois que
je ne crois pas très franchement je
crois que c'est tout activité avec le
cabinet vide alors c'est pas tous les
avocats parce que c'est vrai on peut
dire là que quand on défend la veuve et
l'orphelin quand on des divorces ou de
vend des jeunes Pierre Jacques c'est
beaucoup ça par exemple devant la
justice ça c'est autre chose
mais franchement l'activité d'avocat
d'affaires
je ne pense pas que ce soit ça peut pas
être résolu simplement par des
déclarations d'intérêt parce que ça se
renouvelle en permanence donc ce qui est
vrai à un moment peut être tout à fait
dépassé le lendemain donc je crois que
la sagesse serait de décider que on doit
s'abstenir voilà pendant la durée du
mandat alors après est-ce que ça doit
parce que vous avez les médecins vous
avez les avocats par exemple pour les
médecins il est clair que être attaché à
un laboratoire pharmaceutique quand on
est député non en revanche on va pas me
semble-t-il interdire à des grands
médecins de d'exercer ou même des
médecins de campagne si vous voulez on
en a beaucoup donc je crois qu'il faut
apprécier les différentes situations il
y a pas il y a pas des professions en
tant que tel il faut le faire parce
qu'il faut pas que le Parlement
apparaisse comme étant un îlot qui
serait préservé de toutes ces
contraintes alors dans l'affaire du
Médiator la mission d'information
commençait ces auditions à l'Assemblée
ce mercredi sous la présidence du député
Gérard Bapt première entendu la
pneumologue du CHU de Brest Irène
Frachon la première à avoir alerté sur
les dangers du Médiator témoignage
édifiant ou la pneumologue raconte en
longueur les pressions dont elle a fait
l'objet et l'attitude de la SAPS
l'Agence du Médicament extrait
qu'ils avaient beaucoup plus peur du
laboratoire très clairement que des
conséquences qu'il n'imaginait pas
certainement en termes de gravité
de laisser faire je sais qu'il y a eu
des coups de téléphone au Conseil de
l'Ordre pour savoir s'il y avait moyen
de m'interdire d'exercice qu'il y avait
donc l'évocation de recours à l'Académie
de médecine aux académiciens qui avaient
l'évocation de retour de recours à la
justice et puis un autre mail que j'ai
vu passer également redisait bien les
doutes qu'ils avaient sur la valeur
scientifique de notre étude je ne sais
pas si vous avez pu l'entendre sur la
longueur c'est un incroyable témoignage
ou l'on mesure le degré d'infiltration
de l'air des rouages de la
pharmacovigilance par le laboratoire
Servier et à quel point elle se sentait
démunie
quelles solutions
pour ces conflits d'intérêt notamment ça
c'est une affaire gravissime évidemment
le rapport de yoga c'est très clair donc
je crois qu'il faut en tirer toutes les
conséquences c'est à dire qu'il faut une
refonte complète du système de
pharmacovigilance
est engagé là-dessus vous trouvez qu'il
gère bien ce dossier exactement je pense
en tout cas que il a annoncé des mesures
fortes et j'espère qu'elles vont être
prises voilà et c'est vrai que
il faut arriver
empêcher interdire que les personnes qui
ont un pouvoir de décision sur
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
déjà c'est ça qui importe surtout en
matière de santé publique premièrement
deuxièmement sur le plan économique sur
l'autorisation de remboursement par la
Sécurité Sociale ces deux choses
différentes je veux dire l'autorisation
de mise sur le marché on apprécie la
l'innocuité ou le caractère dangereux
d'un médicament pour le remboursement ou
pas par la Sécurité sociale c'est son
caractère eff
la distance de médicaments mais là
atteint des proportions quelquefois
terribles en revanche on pourrait
soutenir des revues indépendantes comme
prescrire qui elle informe davantage de
façon plus indépendante je crois que
c'est reconnu
les médecins sur les avantages ou les
inconvénients de tel ou tel médicaments
ils perdent leur indépendance pardon si
on les finances ils perdent leur
indépendance
faire connaître c'est une façon de faire
connaître par exemple davantage aux
médecins allez on passe à la journée de
jeudi l'union sacrée sur le Grand Paris
après trois années de rivalité de
dialogues de sourds même l'État et la
région Île-de-France se sont mis
d'accord sur les transports en commun du
futur autour de Paris modernisation des
actuelles RER et nouveau métro
automatique en rocade autour de la
capitale il y en aura pour 32 milliards
d'investissements d'ici 2025 Thomas
soulier
après plus de deux ans de négociation
ils ont du mal à cacher leur sourire
l'État et la région Île-de-France ont
enfin conclu un accord sur le Grand
Paris 32 milliards d'euros vont être
investis dans les transports franciliens
d'ici à 2025 objectif moderniser le
réseau existant et réalisé en métro
automatique autour de la capitale c'est
un effort d'investissement historique
pour les transports il faut du rêve il
faut de l'utopie moi j'assume cela mais
on a aussi besoin des petits cailloux
blancs qui font que les transports des
Franciliens vont s'améliorer
considérablement c'est un véritable
tournant économique sociale écologique
pour l'Île-de-France après avoir dénoncé
la main Miss de l'État sur la région
Jean-Paul Huchon trouve aujourd'hui le
texte mesuré et favorable aux francilien
mais cet accord a du mal à passer au
sein même de sa majorité pour les vers
Jean Peluchon a vendu son âme au diable
on était favorable un rapprochement des
tracés favorable à l'intérêt général sur
les transports en commun en
Île-de-France qui transcendent les
clivages politiques mais pas favorable à
une opération de communication du
gouvernement auquel le président de la
Région s'est prêté et donc quand on voit
les problèmes qui se posent aujourd'hui
dans les transports en commun il est
absolument scandaleux de faire espérer
des solutions qui n'arriveront pas voilà
mais l'accord n'est pas définitif le
débat public continue jusqu'à la fin du
mois et les travaux ne devraient pas
débuter avant 2013 alors Valérie
Pécresse pour l'UMP estime que
finalement le tracé reprend le projet du
gouvernement à 90% c'est Jean pollution
qui a cédé il a bien fait pour vous
moi ce que je vois dans cet accord c'est
que les habitants de la
Seine-Saint-Denis qui est mon
département d'élections
et bien écoutez oui enfin ils avaient
été complètement oublié par le projet de
Christian Blanc il y avait une le Grand
8 là enjambé département de
Seine-Saint-Denis il allait juste il
allait il commence à s'y intéresser à
Roissy
qui est quand même à l'extrémité voilà
c'était un projet qui était fait pour
les hommes d'affaires qui voulaient
aller vite de la défense à Roissy mais
qui en aucun cas s'intéressait aux
populations qui habitaient là nous
étions une zone grise voilà une résolu
maintenant et ça maintenant et c'est
évidemment le projet de la région et des
départements et de tous les élus
d'ailleurs de ce département c'était de
dire mais attendez il faut aussi qu'il y
ait avec les masses financières énormes
qui vont être consacrées qui est ce
projet Arc Express est un projet de
métro qui relie entre elles en boucle si
vous voulez autour de Paris les villes
de Seine-Saint-Denis et qui aurait aimé
en se méritent en plus de
la décision était très attendue pour le
Conseil constitutionnel l'interdiction
du mariage homosexuel est bien conforme
à la Constitution les sages avaient été
saisi d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité par un couple de
femmes pacsées qui souhaitait une plus
grande sécurité juridique pour leurs
enfants votre réaction
je respecte la décision du Conseil
constitutionnelle
la question ce que dit le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est que il appartient
au législateur le cas échéant de faire
évoluer la législation c'est-à-dire de
changer le code civil
je crois que ce qu'il faut car ça c'est
urgent c'est régler en effet la
situation juridique et la question de
l'autorité parentale de ses parents qui
sont en couple homosexuel et qui élève
des enfants et ça c'est pas possible de
rester alors vous avez plusieurs
situations vous avez des enfants que
c'est les membres de ce couple ont eu
avant d'être un couple homosexuel c'est
à dire qu'ils ont eu en étant dans un
hétérosexuel c'est les cas sont très
nombreux vous avez ensuite des enfants
qui ont pu être adoptés parce que chez
nous c'est pas autorisé à l'étranger
donc je crois qu'il est indispensable
que les enfants et cette sécurité
juridique cette s'habiller que les
parents qui élèvent les enfants puissent
se voir reconnus dans leur autorité
parentale
arrive bien et dans les papiers d'état
civil que un enfant est né d'un homme et
d'une femme même si un enfant a dans la
vie sociale et dans sa filiation sociale
de papa et de maman au départ il y a
forcément un homme et une femme parce
que ça c'est la loi de l'expression
humaine
est-ce que oui ou non vous pensez que le
parti socialiste doit faire cette
proposition pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 de proposer donc
une loi qui autoriserait le mariage de
personnes du même sexe je pense que vous
pouvez me dire clairement nous avons
nous avons pris position pour la
légalisation du mariage des couples
homosexuels
nous avons pris position à la faveur des
lois biotiques donc voilà je pense que
c'est une question pour la
présidentielle et un bon
on verra quels sont les priorités moi je
comprends que ça intéresse beaucoup de
monde
vous avez bien vu oui parce que c'était
quelque chose de très sensible dans
l'opinion et là on vous êtes vous êtes
un peu en arrière sur cette affaire là
je suis pas en arrière je dis que ça
pose des questions qui sont compliquées
et qu'il faut résoudre et que je pense
que ça doit se résoudre dans la sérénité
et que ces questions elles ne doivent
pas être l'otage d'un débat politiqueien
voilà alors est-ce que l'élection
présidentielle est le meilleur moment je
ne sais pas moi ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on apporte des réponses sereines aux
questions que ça pose et en particulier
regarde les enfants parce que pense que
la liberté des adultes moi ça me pose
aucun problème au contraire mais dès
lors que des enfants sont en jeu là il y
a quand même certaines questions qu'on
peut pas esquiver qu'il faut traiter
sérieusement et pour finir cette
émission juste un petit duo Fillon
Mélenchon côte à côte pour recevoir le
prix du Trombinoscope François Fillon
couronné homme politique de l'année
Jean-Luc mélachon Mélenchon révélation
politique Julia le Correc
ils sont à la politique ce que les
Oscars sont au cinéma les prix du
Trombinoscope la consécration pour les
meilleurs interprètes de l'année Enzo
meilleur au lit François Fillon triomphe
du fair-play de l'élégance puisque vous
avez choisi un Premier ministre qui ne
présente ni les atouts d'un jeune
premier vous l'avez même qualifié
avait dit que je n'étais pas un enfant
de coeur ni les attraits d'un personnage
décoiffant voilà presque quatre ans que
j'ai l'honneur de servir mon pays à
Matignon et comme à Hollywood le
micro-cosme politique à lui aussi ses
enfants terribles
catégorie Meilleur Espoir à 59 ans tout
de même Jean-Luc Mélenchon plus en forme
que jamais Mesdames et Messieurs les
hypermétropes
vous ne m'avez donc pas vu arriver vous
imaginez le sentiment qui mettra et par
qui révélé
par cela même que j'avais envoyé au
diable bref une affiche de rêve pour la
photo de famille pour les sourires en
revanche prière d'attendre l'année
prochaine
alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon révélation
politique mais aussi épine dans le plié
des socialistes
c'est un excellent orateur personne va
dire le contraire
voilà
maintenant je trouve que il a
il a des prises de position bon il a sa
logique politique moi je crois
profondément que Jean-Luc Mélenchon veut
prendre le contrôle du Parti communiste
voilà donc logique qu'il amène
évidemment à essayer de se démarquer le
plus
possiblement à gauche peut-être plus
évident que celui du Parti socialiste
non mais je crois que la la
présidentielle et législative c'est pas
une course à qui va est-ce que c'est moi
qui suis non c'est est-ce que qui peut
apporter des vraies réponses aux
problèmes des Françaises et des Français
bon je pense que les Françaises et les
Français sont assez mûrs assez adultes
pour voir que c'est pas dans la
surenchère politique pour pas dire plus
que se trouve la réponse à leur problème
que nous allons nous quitter Elisabeth
Guigou merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous Emmanuel C'est non sans une grande
émotion que j'annonce que nous faisions
notre dernière émission ensemble vous
allez nous quitter vous partez vers
d'autres cieux sur LCI la chaîne tout
info voilà vous êtes resté 8 ans
pour moi c'était elisabethigou ce qui
était un plaisir et un grand intérêt
aussi merci à vous voilà
merci à tous des offres aussi à toute
l'équipe pour ces huit années de passion
politique partagée journaliste équipe
technique tous ceux qui ont fait qu'on
fait ces émissions le plus la façon la
plus sérieuse et la plus conviviale à la
fois merci en tout cas à vous d'avoir en
avoir été le témoin bonne chance
Emmanuel pour la suite et puis nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine même
lieu même heure au
revoir